good evening everyone we'd like to get
ourselves underway thank you for your
attention very soon our guest of honor
dr. Hansen will give his lecture on the
second world wars and our topic this
evening of course then is dealing with
military history and it seems that it
would be entirely fitting to acknowledge
that among us we probably have a number
of people who have served in arms for
our country and I would ask all the
veterans in the room to stand and be
recognized
[Applause]
thank you our speaker this night will be
introduced by the president of the
college dr. Larry P Arnn who was the
12th president of Hillsdale College dr.
Ahn received his bachelor's degree from
Arkansas State University and his MA and
PhD degrees in government from the
Claremont Graduate School he served as
director of research for Sir Martin
Gilbert the official biographer of
Winston Churchill dr. Arnn served as
president of the Claremont Institute for
the Study of statesmanship and political
philosophy from 1985 to 2000 in 1996 he
was the founding chairman of the
California Civil Rights initiative which
was passed by California voters and
prohibited racial preferences in state
hiring contracting and admissions dr.
Arnn is on the board of directors of the
Heritage Foundation the Henry Salvatori
center of Claremont McKenna College the
Philadelphia society the intercollegiate
Studies Institute and the Claremont
Institute he served on the US Army War
College Board of Visitors for two years
for which he earned the Department of
Army's outstanding civilian Service
Medal in 2015 dr. Arnn received the
Bradley prize from the Lynde and Harry
Bradley foundation he's a member of the
American Political Science Association
the Churchill Center the council for
national policy the Federal Society the
Mont Pelerin society and the
philanthropy roundtable published widely
in newspapers magazines and periodicals
on issues of Public Policy history and
political theory he is the author of
three books Liberty and learning the
evolution of American education
the founders key the divine and natural
connection between the Declaration and
the Constitution and what we risk by
losing it and Churchill's trial Winston
Churchill and the salvation of free
government dr. Arnn is a professor of
politics and history here at Hillsdale
College he teaches courses on Aristotle
Winston Churchill and the American
Constitution he and his wife Penelope
have forged
Henry Katie Alice and Tony please join
me in welcoming dr. Larry on
[Applause]
it's an exaggeration to say it but I am
mark cost boss mark is one of our senior
professors and I'm grateful to him for
his fabulous work
he's a dutiful department chairman and
he makes his department behave which is
something almost nobody else around here
achieves I think all of you for coming I
want to recognize because he's a friend
of mine and because I don't see him as
much as I like Dave Leffler is here
tonight and Kathy still married to him
nobody understands that congratulations
Dave
[Applause]
a trustee Gunnar Clark is here he's
married to Louise who's from the Searle
family that gave us this room and I just
found out that Gunnar sells beef to
another special guest I'm going to
introduce John Harris in just a minute
and we've just organized the deal I've
bought a bunch of cattle from these guys
and I need volunteers from the students
next summer we're gonna have a cattle
drive from California to Michigan I
[Applause]
don't think we'll get here with any
cattle but what wouldn't that be cool
would you like to do that
yeah yeah see it was all girls that
we're clamping to I give a special
welcome to John and Carol Harris from
near Fresno California where they're
farmers ranchers on a big scale the
famous Harris Ranch but if you live in
California as I did for a long time
everybody knows about that but everybody
knows about it all over and they're
closed good friends of our speaker not
Victor Hansen Victor himself is a fifth
generation farmer from Selma where they
have a big installation in their beef
business and they're just as solid as
the land they farm as is Victor and I
just want to welcome them and say how
probably already have them here tonight
thank you for coming
Victor Hansen has been a distinguished
fellow here since 2004 he teaches every
far every fall he's a born teacher
because of some qualities he has that
I'll mention he's teaching a class this
term on the nature of war and if you eat
in the dining hall when you're in town
as I do you'll find out that his course
when it's going I was always one of the
talking points of the campus everybody
talks about it everybody tries to use my
influence to get into Victor Hanson's
class I'm powerful but maybe not that
much he built a classics program at
Fresno State
he started Stanford in the Naval Academy
and Santa Cruz and Pepperdine and all
over the place oh I meant to mention
because I forgot William Bordeaux who
works for John Harris is over there and
he's sending his kids to Hillsdale
College and Don Meyer a colleague from
California is here and we're glad to
have all those California
victor is the Martin and Ilya Anderson
senior fellow at Hoover he won that
Bradley prize and he's the trustee of
the Bradley Foundation he won the Eric
rondelle prized the Nimitz Leadership
Award in military history the National
Humanities medal given by George W Bush
president the way M F Buckley tried a
prize in the statesmanship award with
the Claremont Institute he won all the
prizes
he's written or edited 24 books and they
are consistently works of scholarship
and also inspiration I myself read them
all the newest one is entitled the
second world wars I've heard him lecture
on that subject twice now and again
tonight I look forward to it I always
learned something although I'm supposed
to know something about that he is one
of those rare men and brings the most
serious knowledge the kinda chief only
by a combination of talent and decades
of devotion but then beyond that he has
a commanding kind of understanding he
makes complex things seem simple he
makes high things seem to be within our
grasp all who attend to him learn from
him and they are legion all over the
country this gift makes him a resource
in any age like ours especially when
things are confused and shifting and
dangerous and when everything seems new
but everything is not new and what
sureness of understanding we can achieve
begins with a deep knowledge of the past
and a comprehending mind that can make
some sense of it you will find if you
get to know him what everybody does and
that is any conversation with him is fun
and a way to learn presidents and prime
ministers have enjoyed that he is
influential in the way that the wise and
the knowing can be please welcome a
great man Victor Hansen
[Applause]
thank you very much for that kind
introduction
I think it's been 16 years since dr.
aren´t showed up in my farmhouse in
Selma California and asked me to teach
her and 14 I came here as a young man of
49 I was turned 64 last week and I
really feel it but I've been very
fortunate you know when you go to a
university as a visitor usually it's
very territorial but when I came to
Hillsdale people in my field of classics
professor raw pave excuse me and Tom
Connor mark Cal called
they were welcoming they wanted me to
teach in their field that was very
unusual and so I felt like I was in a
special place so for the last fourteen
years one month of my life is just
completely schizophrenic I mean here the
way America should work and I'm leaving
a place that I dare Lee love where
America doesn't work California but it's
it's been a schizophrenic experience
it's almost as bad as what living in the
San Joaquin Valley and then working at
Stanford where you go from somewhat
stability into lunacy and I don't know
which one you're going to count as
lunatic or stable but they're very
different I like also to think of John
and Carol Harris that came I grew up and
you know obviously on the farm and the
Harris name in California agriculture is
sort of like Hillsdale this name in in
education it's synonymous with integrity
and respect for the law and it has a
reputation that transcends business
success it's it's really unusual so when
they came I was very thankful for that
I'd like to talk about a book I've
written on World War 2 that's coming out
on October 17th called the second world
wars plural but before I get to that I
I'll speak for about 40 minutes and I
want to ask because I know there's
veterans here and I open it up for
questions but thing that strikes one
about World War two is it was the most
lethal period of six Wars six years in
the history of civilization more deadly
than the six years of the
bubonic or black plague of the 14th
century more deadly than World War 1
more deadly than the Civil War more
deadly than any 6-year period in history
there are greater body counts by Stalin
and Mao of course but it took them
longer so why was it so deadly 27
thousand people died every year of the
six years of World War two
from September 1st 1939 to September 2nd
1945 think about just it's absolutely
astounding one way to look at the war if
you step back from it is it was a war
against the unarmed so of the 60 to 65
million people who died in the six-year
period 80% were not combatants that had
never happened in history it was the
first major war in which the civilian
toll was much greater than the combatant
toll so we want to know what happened
why was it so lethal well ostensibly you
could look at we could reduce World War
two even further and say it was
basically a story of Germans and
Japanese killing people who didn't have
weapons and that's the story of world
war ii 27 million people in the soviet
union were killed by the Vera Marcal and
another five million in Eastern Europe
and Japan killed about three million
people in Asia in the Pacific and
seventeen million Chinese take that away
in World War two is not that unusual
that's important to remember in the
context the war because we were so
obsessed in our generation with
Hiroshima or the bombing of Dresden or
the bombing of Hamburg and we forget
that World War two was a story of
Germans and Japanese killing people who
had no weapons why was it so lethal
though aside from the civilian toll why
was it so lethal in a way that the other
wars had not been one of them was the
world had never been more populated by
1939 there were 2 billion people living
so there were more people living and
more people to die the second was that
there was not just nationalism or
territorial chauvinism or even ethnic
chauvinism but there was an ideology by
that I mean that Italian fascism made
Italy do things in Libya and Somalia
that it did not do in World War one and
Nazism or National Socialism made the
German army do things and the German
Third Reich do things that even it had
not considered under the worst moments
of Prussian militarism and it made
Japanese nationalism fascism in Japanese
and it had not done in the Franco excuse
me the Japanese Russian war of 1905 and
six take those players away from World
War two and you have a war and the
Soviet Union as well the Soviet Army
committed atrocities kilfer two million
German prisoners not as much as they
lost five million but Nazis killed
Russian prisoners but they did things
that the Czarist Army had never done
take those ideologies out of the
equation and it was a pretty humane war
if you look at what the American army
and the British Army did in comparison
but AD fascism and communism and Nazism
into the mix and a lot of people being
alive at that time and people not being
prepared for the advent of fascism in
Russia and China and you have the
ingredients for 65 million dead one
final thing to remember is this was at a
peak of Western technology that the
world had never seen and more
importantly we all have Western
technology that has a challenge response
challenge you have catapult you build
walls you build bigger catapults bigger
walls you have armor on a knight then
you can't penetrate to get a cross post
but at this particular cycle the
offensive was predominant by that I mean
the war started with biplanes it ended
with jets
it started with World War one artillery
shells it ended with proximity fuses v1
and v2 rockets it started with the
knowledge of chlorine gas was used by
the Japanese but not in your
but it ended with Zaycon B and the death
camps so the technological fury of 20th
century technology explains a lot and
the fact that we were in an offensive
cycle we're sort of in a defensive hot
cycle today where we have missile
defense we have the ability to shoot
down incoming planes we have body armor
all that in this particular cycle was
not there so it was much easier to kill
people in mass and we'll work through
technologically ideologically
politically than it has ever been any
think time when I say second world wars
I refer just really quickly to two
things when the war started on September
1st when Germany invaded Poland followed
three weeks later by their Russian
Soviet invasion of Poland people still
referred to World War one or what the
British call the first world war as the
great war nobody had envisioned this as
any other thing than a intensive version
of what Nazis do all the time in the
last decade they had gone and
militarized the Rhineland they had sort
of stepped over the bounds a little bit
in the Saarland plebiscite they had the
on sluice which was forbidden in
Versailles they had destroyed
Czechoslovakia and they went into Poland
this time Hitler didn't believe that
they would be declared war on by France
and Britain they did but nothing really
happened so Hitler thought this is just
another border war and he prepared the
Third Reich for that purpose and what
had followed Poland of course was the
destruction of Denmark the destruction
of Norway later the destruction of the
Low Countries Belgium Luxembourg the
Netherlands France and by April of 1941
yuccas la vía in Greece and the Blitz
against Britain but all of these had
something in common they were all border
wars or wars against neighbors and forth
at the BRIT the fascist powers had been
preparing for a decade nearly and the
Allied powers had not what do I mean by
that I mean empirically if you look at
the German army seventy five percent of
it was still horse powered they were not
so worried about gasoline for their pens
they were more worried about pasturage
and hay for their horses the tanks that
went into Poland had a 20 millimeter gun
the planes that flew stupid the dreaded
Stukas were obsolete within a year what
I'm trying to suggest is these were a
series a border war we can even call in
them bully wars until they did to things
that they had not anticipated they had
declared war in Britain and they had no
strategic method to defeat Britain think
of that you declare war in an enemy and
you have no means to limit their
production by that mean the British Navy
was the largest Navy in the world
Germany was not even a close 7th or 8th
they had no aircraft carriers they were
outnumbered in destroyers cruisers
battleships they had no means to achieve
naval superiority they could not invade
Britain they could not cut written off
by sea even though they had a very
successful u-boat they could not bomb
Britain they had no idea that in the
worst moment of the Blitz Winston
Churchill was producing more airframes
of spitfire supermarine fighters than
were me-109 think of that the present EU
all under the control of one government
all the way from the English Channel to
the borders with Russia and Little
Britain was producing more Spitfires and
the Germans were producing 109s so they
had no conception of who the British
were and they hit a obstacle the second
thing that this sort of border wars
found is they invaded the Soviet Union
and that changed everything and changed
the second world wars into a global war
because for the first time the very mark
was not fighting someone next to their
borders fighting someone a outnumbered
infighting someone that was clearly
technologically inferior they were
fighting in an army that was three times
their size and had plans for a t-34 tank
that was better than anything that they
had and could be supplied generously by
the British Empire in the United States
by naval convoys and the
had no way to deflect it that process
then changed border wars that were all
had certain things in common the German
army fought people nearby they spot them
to surprise surprise and they had easy
logistics and they were numerically or
they were militarily unprepared and then
they found out that Britain didn't quite
fit that bill the Soviet Union didn't
quite fit that bill and by December 7th
when they'd the Japanese bombed Pearl
Harbor the United States didn't fit that
bill then they got into a global war but
they could not win and I'd like to walk
us through there through that process
very quickly but one other reason that I
use the plural was that this was the
first war that was almost unconnected
there were two billion people on the
planet 1 billion people were actively
engaged in the war either fighting it or
preparing to fight it industrially or in
manufacturing by the time the war ended
there was only about eight nations that
had not declared war and was one of the
two sides but if you were in a u-boat in
the North Atlantic you had no experience
of what a combatant was doing in the
jungles of water canal if you were
25,000 feet up in a b-29 over the
Marianas taking off you had no idea what
Ramos Panzers were doing in North Africa
and it wasn't just that the theaters
were so diverse but the mechanisms and
the methodology of fighting you could be
in a tank you could be on the ground you
can be in artillery you could be in a
heavy cruiser you can be in a high
bomber this had never really happened
before most Wars a civil war or First
World War were one-dimensional there had
been u-boats in the World War one but
they were not three dimensional or maybe
even four dimensional fighting on the
surface fighting below the surface
fighting on land fighting on the air and
so it was so complicated and complex
that people didn't know really what to
call it once once Germany invaded Russia
then the idea of border wars disappeared
and now we were in World
- and the Anglosphere we called the
second world war and we went back and
renamed the first world war not as the
great war but World War one or the first
world war so what happened why didn't he
in Japan and Italy go to war because
Germany had won these border wars and it
had a numerical superiority over Britain
maybe not the British Empire but in 1941
by May there were 80 million Germans and
there was only 45 million Britons and
that was all that was left there was no
other major power fighting in the Third
Reich or Italy except Britain and they
were outnumbered two to one and yet in
six months Hitler managed to change that
equation that even with the addition of
78 million Japanese he was going to be
outnumbered two to one so he went from
outnumber in his enemy two to one to
being outnumbered two to one once he
brought in 300 million Russians and
Americans into the problem but why would
he do such a stupid thing when you asked
why people start wars there's always the
superficial reason what started that
fighting and why didn't somebody
existentially are theoretically wanting
to go to war well Hitler still went into
Poland a win of these countries and he
went into the Soviet Union because no
one had stopped him he felt that the
United States was isolationist Britain
Britain had been appeasing and prior
governments prior to Churchill the
Soviet Union to be colluding he didn't
think anybody would really want to
expend treasure and blood to stop the
mark they did they had seen what he had
done against weaker powers and they were
intimidated he was quite right people in
the United States Charles Lindbergh
people in the Soviet Union said Stalin
went in some type of catatonic fit for
two weeks people really did believe that
the very mark was unstoppable they were
not empirical they did not measure
actually the size of the army the
equipment of the army and compare it to
the resources that he was up against so
what I'm saying is that Hitler was crazy
to do such a thing to bring in 200 300
million people the largest economy in
the world
United States and remember within five
years the US GDP will be larger than all
of the six major belligerents together
and yet he declared war on us on
December 11 so why would he do such a
thing he these countries lost deterrence
but more importantly in the last 20
years the German people had believed
that as losers of World War one they had
been cheated of a victory because they
had they had surrendered seventy miles
in Belgium and France and almost
immediately when the army came back they
said this was an armistice this was not
an unconditional surrender
we were stabbed in the back by Jews and
communists we could have won we knocked
out Czarist Russia they capitulated we
again X 50 million people and a million
square miles we had a treaty with them
the Progress LaCava and yet we lost the
war we shouldn't have lost the war and
then when they signed the Versailles
Treaty they had the worst combination a
treaty could imagine it was punitive and
humiliating and weak it put war guilt on
Germany and made them pay reparations
and yet it didn't occupy Germany as we
did in World War two we had no mechanism
to enforce the Versailles Treaty and
very quickly the German sized up the
Allies that in their victory they were
depressed and in their defeat the
Germans were confident so if you read
war poetry in between the wars or you
look at French textbooks the messages we
never want another song we never want
another Verdun if you look what Germany
is doing at the same time we want
another bought Verdun and we want
another song because this time we're
going to win and yet only one person
knew that that's Winston Churchill the
only country that was left before the
Third Reich went into the Soviet Union
so after this war started in Japan also
had had sense that the United States had
lost deterrence they did something
equally foolish it had the third largest
Navy in the world but we were second but
what they didn't realize or they did
realize is we were second but we would
be the largest Navy in the world within
12 months and within 24 months
would have a navy that was larger than
every other Navy in the world combined
we had on order seven battleships 60
destroyers a hundred submarines and most
importantly 27 essex carriers and with
light and escort we would build a
hundred and forty-five aircraft carriers
and yet they had they attacked the
country of that magnitude why because
they felt that we either would not fight
or if we thought we would fight fight
how heartedly they said in in japanese
memos and communications they said well
that their closest friend was britain
they just watched it they just watched
it be bombed they didn't lift a finger
they they just barely had a drop by one
vote
half their fleets in europe they're not
serious and people in the japanese war
department said just don't don't touch
Pearl Harbor and take the Dutch East
Indies Holland doesn't exist
take Southeast Asia France doesn't exist
anymore you can have everything you want
just don't touch the United States at
Pearl Harbor the Philippines and the
Japanese war minister said why they
don't want to fight and saying voices in
Japan said we you have no ability just
like Germany has no ability Germany has
no ability to go to Moscow they don't
have the logistical capability they have
no ability to bomb written and you have
no ability to bomb San Diego much less a
place like Detroit and yet you're
declaring war in a country that you
cannot defeat but again they thought
because that we had lost deterrence and
that we wouldn't react in the way we did
or if we wanted to react in the way we
did we wouldn't have a capability
because we hadn't shown that in the
1930s so the war basically was a story
once Germany and Italy a declared war on
us three days after four days after
Pearl Harbor it was a simple story of
will the Allies the Soviet Union and the
United States and Great Britain will
they be able to fight like axis soldiers
will they be as deadly as the deadly
Japanese and will they be as deadly as
German soldiers
or will German and Japanese economies be
able to produce as many war materials
and weapons as the Allies so we had to
do was we had the industrial ability but
we didn't know we had a 17th largest
army in the world and the Soviets had
been very very poorly performing in
Finland they had been late when they
invaded Poland they hadn't done well
when they sent advisor to the Spanish
Civil War Britain seemed like it was
half-hearted they hadn't they were still
standing and had a standoff that Dunkirk
they had to evacuate so the question was
the axis said well they can't fight like
we do but we can learn to produce like
they do and in fact the exact opposite
happened the United States as you know
from Guadalcanal as early as November of
1942 American members of the 1st Marine
Division were as deadly as Japanese
without any more material support
british soldiers fought as well as
Rommel in North Africa Soviet Union the
Red Army within a year was this deadly
or more deadly than the very mark it
didn't seem that that was foreordained
if we had taken a date in late 1942 the
Madden designs of Hitler and Tojo almost
seemed they almost seemed to bear
fruition they thought you know what they
haven't really geared up yet we've been
in the war almost a year and if you
looked over the map Hitler would say
we're a hundred miles from Grozny and
all of the Caspian oil that supplies the
Soviet Union our soldiers have just
climbed Mount Airy Erebus in the caucus
mountain highest mountain in Europe we
own territory from the Volga River to
the English Channel from Norway and the
Arctic Circle all the way to the Sahara
Desert we have were almost surrounded
we're still surrounded Moscow we
blockaded Leningrad we've taken Kiev
Rommel has just accepted the British
surrender in June 23rd at Tobruk the
Americans have lost the Philippines the
British have lost
Singapore that Japanese have now
destroyed in a series of devastating
this is after the Battle of Midway
devastating sea battles off Guadalcanal
they have destroyed every single carrier
in the Pacific except the crippled
enterprise and now they are on the
offensive Aguada canal and if they take
water canal they've cut off the lifeline
to Australia so it looked like that that
we had not been able to fight like they
are and we hadn't really geared up yet
but they were producing material like we
were and then it all vanished
within six months Americans became
British became Russians became much more
skull for soldiers the United States
didn't produce 30,000 airframes 40,000
airframes that produced a hundred
thousand airframes per year it didn't
produce twenty or thirty thousand it
produced 55,000 German tanks Soviet
Union produced 60,000 Stalin and t-34
tanks we supplied two thousand
locomotives to the Soviet Union four
hundred thousand four hundred thousand
heavy trucks a type of production that
nobody had ever seen before everybody
had said Roosevelt's a socialist
he's a central planner nobody thought he
would turn over the war effort to people
like William Knudsen and Charles Wilson
some of the most brilliant people at
General Electric General Motors Ford
Motor Company Henry Ford producing a b24
every hour 30 miles from here at Willow
Run and so we overwhelmed the axis in an
amazing time of less than four years
nobody had ever thought that would be
possible and we did in a combination of
economic superiority but we learned a
fight in a way that was much better
there were three or four there are
things that explain why this war which
could have gone on for 20 years 27 in
the Peloponnesian wars cases it could
have gone on longer but it didn't
another reason that was very short and I
hesitant to use the word short because
as I said 60 million people were killed
but the Allies were very diverse
politically there was communist Russia
Democratic American Americans
parlamentary and monarchic all Britain
with an empire you think they would not
get along on the other hand there was
fascist Italy fascist Germany and
fascist Japanese they would all
coordinate just the opposite happened
something about the nature of fascism
that was inherent in line was inherent
and fascism double-dealing so in Hitler
women to the Soviet Union Italy had no
idea they invaded Japan said my gosh
they're gonna invade the Soviet Union we
fought them in 1939 we're gonna conclude
a non non-aggression pact with the
Soviet Union Hitler said you can't do
that we're going to invade and they said
you did it to us when we were fighting
and then Hitler said well don't get mad
at me for going the Soviet Union you
never told us you were going into Greece
and yet because there were at least two
of three partners on the Allies side
that were transparent and consensual
those governments as early as Casablanca
basically figured out a way to cooperate
for all the evil of the Soviet Union
there was only one Soviet Union not
three so the Allies were able to task
out jobs they said to the Soviet Union
your job is destroyed of their mark on
the land and indeed they did 75% of all
soldiers and the German army were killed
by Russians their job was not and they
said to the owlet you do not have to
fight in Italy do not have to fight
North Africa you do not have to stop the
u-boat campaign you do not have to fight
the Japanese you don't have to do
strategic bombing just fight we will
give you boots we will give you radios
we will give you food will give you
uniforms will give you truck we will
mechanize but just destroy the German
army on the Eastern Front and the
British will and the Americans will
handle the Japanese they will handle
strategic bombing and there was a very
sophisticated outsourcing of tasks in
the ways that the axis never cooperated
the Oxus had very good airplanes if the
Japanese had just got the plans earlier
of a 262 MIG excuse me at the
Messerschmitt if they had just been able
to deal with the Germans on the
focke-wulf 190 engine if the Italians
could have just borrowed some early mark
3 designs of surplus German tanks they
would have been okay there was no such
cooperation when the Sherman tank met
the tiger tank in 1944 in Normandy the
British said the great tank it's
reliable its pragmatic its durable but
it's not under gun so we have a 17
pounder we think we can put that huge
barrel in your tank when we had a p-51
it was the best aerial dynamic fighter
in the world but it had an Allison
engine the British said we have a Merlin
old rolls-royce engine such cooperation
would be unheard of with the axis Hitler
would have said let's steal it or don't
give him the designs the British said
here's the designs for the Merlin engine
you can make it in the United States and
it up the speed by 75 miles an hour it
made the best fighter in the world that
was very important that there was this
cooperation there was another thing as
well it was quite different from the two
sides that explains its in asking
explicable victories so quickly that the
bullies lost and as I said once the war
got globally lost in four years and
another reason was the attitude toward
war production the fascist powers had a
nineteenth-century idea that morale
along battlefield prowess with Trump
logistics material and there's something
to that as you know through military
history but the Allies were far more
pragmatic so if he wanted a tank the
Germans said well a Sherman tank is not
very good we met it it's got a 75
millimeter even the 76 millimeter gun
can't penetrate either a panther or a
tiger it's only got three inches of
armor Czar's have six we can blow them
apart into two miles away and the
americans said in answer to this maybe
so but not if there's one tiger or one
Panther on the bow
field for every six Sherman's and you
just bypass a German tank and let the
Air Force deal with it and you attack
infantry that have no tanks or they said
we have to go see we have to go three
Mont three thousand miles so we have to
pick up a tank on a crane and put it in
a ship be nice to have a 60 or 70 ton
king tiger but what would we do with him
we couldn't even pick him up and put him
on ships they wouldn't fit and then they
said the designers of the Sherman tank
I've got a Chrysler engine you can go
ten hours for one hour of maintenance
tiger tank can go one hour for one hour
of maintenance you can take out a
Sherman transmission in three hours you
have to take that's Tiger tanks
transmission from the Ukraine and put it
on a rail and send it back to the
factory
Porsche factory in Germany so there was
this idea that we're gonna be practical
we don't have to build the best weapons
they have to be reliable they have to be
durable and integral to this philosophy
is we're not going to be addicted to the
idea of gigantism that's the age old
idea that a weapon is good if it's big
sort of like Demetrios that the seizure
built this huge Heliopolis to take loads
took so much capital labor and it fell
over and that's what the Japanese did
they said we have the largest
battleships in the world the yeah moat
Miyamoto and the Mousasi seventy one
thousand tons they were the largest
warships until the 1960s when US
aircraft carrier exceeded that tonnage
those two ships together sunk one of a
hundred and forty five American carriers
that's all they did in the entire war
they call it the hotel Musashi because
it was so expensive to get out of Port
it had an 18 inch gun they could fire 27
miles but Americans could blow it up at
sea very easy with a carrier and that's
what happened to both of them but
Bismarck and the Tirpitz were wonderful
bit ships in fact in a an old-fashioned
battle as you know the Bismarck blew up
the hood
and disabled the Prince of Wales and
that was it it was quickly sunk the
Tirpitz the most expensive ship that
Germany ever built they could have built
25 destroyers or 30 30 the 30 u-boats
or 5000 priceless 88 millimeter
anti-tank guns and yet they built the
Tirpitz and it fired one salvo and anger
the entire war they had a weapons
program that was the most expensive we
thought 1 billion dollars in dollars the
v2 and the v1 rocket programs v1 was a
simple cruise missile v2 was an
basically an intercontinental missile
those together terrified Britain they
killed 11,000 Britons the two programs
together but the cost to deliver a pound
of explosive was 30 times more expensive
than a lumbering Lancaster or b-17 we
burned down the cities of Japan and
Germany very cheaply if who can be so go
test and they spent all her money
dreaming of a vengeance weapon that did
almost no vet doubt value at all we had
2 billion dollar weapons programs
the b-29 program and 14 months we built
a bomber it had 20,000 rivets in the
cone alone it had over 150,000 parts as
the most complex bomber in the world but
it destroyed 65% of the urban core of
Japan in four months and we had a
Manhattan Project that after Nagasaki
and Hiroshima along with the bombing
that forced Japan to surrender so our
idea of weapons programs and spending
large amounts of capital were not in
obsolete dinosaurs that were battleships
or rail guns Germans had 7500 men that
the Manning a Gustaf rail gun that shot
a 400 millimeter projectile into
Sevastopol and it could do that about a
hundred and twenty times and you had
change the barrel finally they were of
no value they represented about 7,000
88-millimeter platforms that were not
built so that American practicality and
British practicality even Soviet was
much different than the world of fantasy
that Mussolini Tojo and Hitler lived in
that too was a reason that the war ended
as quickly as it did and finally you
could argue that the German and Japanese
generals general Hama or Yamaguchi or
von Bach or von Rundstedt or Guderian or
Roma were comparable to Patton
comparable to ylim a comparable maybe to
Nimitz and Halsey and you can make that
argument but you cannot argue that
Hitler Mussolini and Tojo had the
strategic knowledge that Stalin
Roosevelt and Churchill did the big
three did not do things like invade
China and find themselves in a quagmire
of 12 years it would eat up a million
soldiers they did not in 1944 when they
were losing the war invade Burma and try
to go into India they did not do
something stupid like invade the Soviet
Union without any knowledge that there
was such a thing as a t-34 coming off
they did stupid things they lost two
Broke they lost Singapore they lost
Corregidor but these were all manageable
and correctable they did not and why
didn't they do it because Roosevelt and
Churchill did not say I want to do this
Churchill said I want to go and
something stupid and I want to go into
roads or I want to attack the island the
Ionian Islands people in a consensual
Society said don't and they hashed it
out when Hitler said I want to go in the
Soviet Union you should read the minutes
on the bear marks okay W don't do it but
they didn't tell him that he could do
whatever he wanted so they had a mythic
leadership that was nursed on these
cheap easy victories of the mid-1930s
against underpowered and unprepared
enemies and they translated that into
wrongly concluding that they were
actually
formidable power and they went to war
against the three most powerful
countries in the world and they lost and
it was quite predictable after 1941 let
me just finish by asking ourselves did
World War two achieve anything and the
answer of course is yes the aim of World
War two was to stop the horrific
governments and Italy Japan and fast and
fascist Germany Nazi Germany it did that
late but it was late but it did save
half of European Jews six million were
killed six million survived the point
was that it went into Eastern Europe to
free use of Eastern Europe from the
dangers of totalitarianism
if however as Franklin Roosevelt saw as
Churchill didn't that the purpose of the
war was not just to defeat these three
ugly Hydra heads of fascism but to end
war altogether and how the United
Nations and under the aegis of the
paternalistic United States both tell
the Soviet Union to behave and Britain
to give up its empire then everything
would be wonderful it didn't work at all
because we went to free Eastern Europe
and Eastern Europe was on free under
Soviet rather than German domination and
so if you want to be perfect than you if
you define victory and wars being
perfect and you can't be good but we
fulfilled all of our names but if your
aims are redefined as something
impossible then we felt wow the war
didn't work because our ally the Soviet
Union became our enemy Germany in
conclusion let's just finish with five
minutes and look at the individual six
belligerence what happened after the war
of the axis power Italy got off pretty
easy
there were no war crime trials there
were no reparations Italy was not
occupied why was that well largest
foreign population the United States who
identified separately Germans had been
all assimil
integrated we're Italian Americans that
help the Pope and the Vatican help and
the Italians throughout Mussolini they
said on their own
and Italy was fought over for three and
a half years by Germans on behalf of
Italian fascist and then against Italy
and the idea was well what there was
Germany only had war in its soil for
three months Japan never did
Italy suffered we're gonna let Italy go
did Italy suffer it lost a million point
one soldiers more than it did in World
War one it committed terrible atrocities
in Somalia and Libya and yet people said
it had suffered enough and for what
it had gambled on her mercy Mussolini it
got off pretty closely it was occupied
and integrated into the Western alliance
if you look at Japan people think Japan
was nude it was the only country ever to
be on the receiving end of a nuclear
weapon that's true and it's tragic but
the nuclear to the nuclear weapon drops
at Hiroshima and Nagasaki killed about
30% of those Japanese that were killed
through conventional napalm by b-29 fire
race that toll number was about 600,000
Japanese Japan lost a total of three
million for a country that had started
the war and made it global in December
of 1941 by declaring war on the United
States and Britain and had been fighting
a war of genocide in China they came off
pretty easily they were not invaded they
were occupied but we insisted they have
things that turned out quite beneficial
land reform the franchise for women and
we were pretty benign occupier for a
country that had killed nine people for
every person they lost it was the most
efficient killing machine in World War
two when you look at the Japanese army
did in the Pacific not just against
Americans and British but Islanders
people in Java people in Southeast Asia
in China a Japanese soldier was the most
lethal soldier in the war
in terms of how many people he killed
versus Khamenei he lost Germany this
time around after Versailles nobody said
I don't really know who started the war
the arms merchants maybe it was
mobilization no nobody said any of those
stupid things this time they said you
started the war and we're going to
occupy you and we're going to divide
your country in four parts and you're
not going to be able to rearm and you're
not going to be able to have a military
capability comparable to your former
enemies and so we occupied the country
we put a gun to their head and said this
time you're going to have a democracy
it's not going to be like why more and
we're not going to do what we did it
Versailles and you know what the world
said by any objective measure that was
much tougher than the Versailles Treaty
and not a person said anything they
didn't say you can't do that that's
meaner than Versailles they still said
Versailles was too mean but they never
said that the peace imposed on Germany
after World War two that was much meaner
was mean at all
such was the anger at Germany and so
East and West Germany came out of that
division we incorporated at NATO and it
became part of the Western alliance it
exploded today we see that much weaker
economies and smaller populations in
France and Britain have nuclear weapons
Germany doesn't and that's for a reason
isn't that and I would say that one of
the formulas after looking at these axis
and I liked I like soldiers one of the
forms I want to get the Soviets in the
United States to conclude but one of the
formulas after world war two was
incorporated NATO the way to keep the
peace is not to have the United Nations
necessarily it's to keep Russia out of
Europe and the United States in Europe
and Germany down and today if you look
at that formula as long as the United
States is engaged with alliances and
balance of powers it's able to preempt
situations that would lead into global
wars
as long as you have a country like the
Soviet Union by extension Japan China
that can be contained those totalitarian
autocratic governments that have large
populations and territories will not
start a global war and as long as you
can have a very dynamic country like
Germany with a very checkered history
you're okay as someone you're going to
say well I'm German American how can you
say that and I can say that after just
coming back from Germany and the Czech
Republic I heard this from Germany's
neighbors Germany's back they're telling
everybody in Eastern Europe that we have
to have an immigration suicidal
immigration just like they do people in
southern Europe said they're running a
mercantile system where they
artificially lower their deutsche mark
under the guise of using the euro and
were in hock to them the rest of their
life and people in Britain are saying
they don't have to be so punitive on the
brexit and the reason that that's not
going to translate into a world war is
that they're disarmed and they have two
nuclear neighbours France and Britain
that are not gonna let him arm again so
that formula after World War two kept
the peace and it's a tribute to the
geniuses who crafted at Churchill and
Roosevelt especially Anthony Eden people
like George Marshall and finally how did
the United States and the Soviet Union
and Great Britain do Soviet Union lost
27 million people most of any country in
the war its land was occupied for most
fertile and industrial sections were
occupied for four years it suffered a
great deal but it went to war so that it
would never have to be vulnerable again
and that that object was fulfilled it
got all of Eastern Europe is a buffer
zone it broke every agreement that had
made with the Allies about free
elections and places like Poland a
Hungarian Hungarian Hungary or Romania
it never gave the Baltic States back it
kept territory had stole from Finland so
in the Communist way of thinking the war
to free as I said totalitarian control
of Eastern Europe ended up guaranteeing
it and the Soviet Union's were quite
happy with that we should know in pass
that of all the six belligerents the
Soviet Union in World War one made a
deal with every other belligerent they
had cut a non-aggression pact with
Germany and Italy they cut a
non-aggression pact with Japan they cut
a alliance with the United States they
cut an alliance with Britain and they
basically broke all of their agreements
with our allies that saved them and they
never broke one agreement with their
axis that tried to destroy them they
were the most duplicity of all the
powers and and World War two and they
came out for all the misery and death
that they suffered they came out in a
stronger position than they had gone
into the war in which communism had been
discredited there were the great famines
the great terror the liquidation of the
officer corps and people thought it was
a real empower it was set to be a
superpower in the Cold War we should
give more credit to Britain Britain was
the only country to folks fight the
first day of the war September 1st 1939
or September 2nd when it declared and in
the last day of the war September 2nd it
was the only country that fought Nazi
Germany by itself for over a year it was
the only country that went to war in
World War two without being attacked in
a surprise attack by an enemy and
without attacking another country it
went to war for the idea of helping
Poland and Britain as I said outproduced
Germany and every aspect of munitions
except tanks but think of it artillery
pieces vehicles planes bombers fighters
ships it was one of the most we think of
the United States but it given its much
smaller industrial base in population
its
war production was just as impressive
what happened after the war was sort of
tragic because if you look at the war -
and you could the post-war era and you
compare it today there was no Chinese
juggernaut it was flattened there was no
Russian it was flattened there was no
Japan it was flat and there was no
Germany it was flat and there was no
France had been occupied there are only
two countries that were going to supply
the world
trucks and appliances and they were
Britain in the United States and the
tragedy is the man who'd won the war
they displaced and they brought in a
socialist government and they
nationalized their coal their steel
their power the help almost everything
and within ten years they were not as
competitive as the countries that were
in rubble at least not until the
resurgence of Margaret Thatcher and
finally the United States pretty
brilliant we had 12 point 1 million
people in the military we waged that we
were the only country to wage a war and
every single theater of World War two
whether it was Burma whether it was
high-altitude bombing over Japan whether
it was nuclear war whatever it was we
fought we lost the smallest number of
people per military soldiers deployed of
any country in the entire world Oh point
three percent 420,000 out of 12.1
million so it was a brilliant effort to
save lives through the use of capital
and machinery the war led to some very
good things that led to the integration
of troops because we had campaigned our
propaganda said we're here to our poor
freedoms and that [ __ ] had to be
redeemed with the integration of blacks
into the military by Korea and women
were in factories so it had positive
social effects it gave the United States
power and a role in the world that only
Britain had had enjoyed in the past and
you could say that Americans did not
make the mistake they did after World
War two
they stayed engaged and they kept a
peace for 70 years
let me just finally sum up and say well
if all that was true did we really have
to go to the war to prove all that and
that way to look at it I think is that
war is like a laboratory experiment in
this room if we didn't like each other
we would know who was strong and who was
weak by their size or their prior
experience in fighting but maybe we
didn't and we would say stupid things
and we would find themselves a stronger
person might be angry at a weaker person
and what worden does it's the testing
that shows you reality it's tragedy
because you shouldn't have to do that
and by that I mean the United States
were the largest economy even in the
Depression years did not have to spend
point five percent under defense if we
had a four percent GDP - and a pact with
France Germany was said I'm never gonna
go into France they landed two million
people in World War one I don't want
that again and they would have stopped
if Britain had have said we want
Churchill in 1937 and he's going to give
us 450 airframes a month and we're going
we have a better plane than German
Goering would have said I don't want to
go into there if Stalin had have said we
would have had t-34 tanks and great
numbers Hitler himself said if I had
have known how many tanks they had that
were of the caliber that t-34 I would
have never gone into Russia but people
forget that so they're nursed on ideas
of utopian idealism Kent military
spending is a waste and they lose
deterrence and with the loss of
deterrence you lose the perception of
who's strong and who's weak and then the
laboratory comes into play and says I'll
show you who's strong and weak and 60
million people have to prove what we
should have known from the very
beginning of the war the Soviet Union
the United States and Great Britain were
much more deadly than the fascist powers
of Italy Germany and Japan thank you
very much
[Applause]
Michael Goldstein you have State
Director for playing justices and
Nations and a student in World War two
I have a question about the Japanese
strategy before the word their strategy
was to lure the American family into the
western Pacific him of the family there
were submarines and land-based in there
and then beat them in the jugglin style
but then didn't come masticated why to
destroy battle to feed their what was
their thinking understand that the
American industrial capacity would be
put to use and the Americans didn't they
fought holding action in the Pacific but
they didn't have to come West until we
had our huge battle fleet and we're
ready to do it was it just hubris or
they really thought we wouldn't fight
very quickly I think Admiral Yamamoto
has a very inflated reputation because
basically on the premise that he said
supposedly that I can raise hell for six
months and after that it can go whether
he said that or not we don't know but we
do know that he was the one not the
Japanese evil people we always associate
with the Tojo regime that wanted to
start the war he threatened to resign if
he didn't get the attack Pearl Harbor
and he didn't have a plan to deal with
the three carriers if they were not
there and they weren't there he had no
idea how to deal with the 27 that would
soon be on order and so he either sunk
or he submerged battleships seven that
had been built in 1917 1622 that were
obsolete and that's not a good way to
start a war against the largest economic
power so that what I'm getting at is if
you ask Yamamoto today after Pearl
Harbor what's next he would say well
I've crushed their battles so they won't
fight they're humiliated the way that we
did to end the
the Japanese Russian war and that's
about the limit of a strategic thinking
I don't know why we ordered a
assassination attempt on him in 1943
that was successful we killed him with
p-38s long-range fighters because if we
had left him in he would have done even
stupider thing because his strategy at
Midway was absolutely insane he split
his forces up and he had a huge
advantage and carriers cruisers
battleships and he wasted those assets
in Alaska so he was not a strategic
thinker I sorry I went a little bit long
because I didn't want to have more
question yeah much the movie Dunkirk the
other day don't know if you've seen it
or yeah I reviewed it on it what about
the red that there were actually the
Germans were surrounding the British and
French but just sat there for two three
days they did because Hitler would not
give them the go watch what's your
inclination to think about why they want
to hear a conspiracy theory or what
happened the conspiracy theory is that
Hitler was going to stop the certain
destruction of British and French forces
and as in return for that token of
magnitude Churchill was going to say
okay
we appreciate what you've done and the
bloody British monarchy some members of
the monarchy some aberrant members and
the aristocracy want to cut a deal
that's did not happen I think I think
much more likely as the German Panzers
had gone through the Ardenne and they
had been fighting for six weeks we
forget we just say the fall of France
they were wiped out Germany suffered to
about two hundred thousand casualties
and they lost somewhere between 30 to 40
thousand dead and missing from the
French and the British and their
wonderful defeat and they were
completely exhausted that was one reason
and they were weak riah quipping and
they thought that the u-boat presence
and the presence of the Luftwaffe gave
them superiority over the channel and
Britain did not have the where
all to get the men out so they said we
don't we want to rest we want to
re-equip and then they're not going to
go anywhere because we have air
superiority and the British don't want
to go into the waters with u-boats and
so they waited three days and that
turned to be about to be quite stupid
because the British were much more
resourceful than the Germans thought and
then the final thing to add to that is
that Hermann Goering was not a doubting
or half Arnold and so he was one of the
most incompetent members of the Reich
and he was a commander of the Luftwaffe
and he assured Hitler that his Luftwaffe
could handle could achieve it not just
air supremacy purity of it air supremacy
and wiped them out at their choosing and
he didn't realize that not only were
British fighters better than the 109
under with good pilots but even French
fighters were as good some of their
models and so they fought very
effectively they took a terrible beating
but the Luftwaffe would lose over France
about 1,500 fighters over the fall of
France and another 1,600 over Britain so
that when they win into the Soviet Union
they were three thousand planes short so
we talked about the Blitz or the
cowardly French but we don't realise
that their contribution and airpower
damage to the Luftwaffe may have saved
the Soviet Union any other questions you
can enroll a book called the unnecessary
war yes to the extent I think he meant
that if Hitler had been stopped sooner
you know
yeah I reviewed that book as well on
YouTube
very strange due to Christopher Hitchens
and I were supposed to debate that book
but we ended up agreeing that the thesis
was not persuasive because there had
been a movement it's very logical and I
said Stalin killed more people in Hitler
house and he's got a dynamic ideology
that transcends race and religion
communism Hitler's ideology is confined
to Arianism it's not going to appeal to
people people in Burma or in
China so let him fight it out and then
people started to suggest that the
Soviet Union would probably lose and if
Germany got its hands I don't mean that
they looked at this empirically if
thought in advance I'm not suggesting
that Buchanan was wrong that there were
communist sympathizers in the State
Department there were but the
preponderance of opinion among American
military minds was Germany if will
probably defeat the Soviet Union unless
we help them and we can give the Soviet
Union areas we can help areas that allow
to free them up and to do what they do
well they do two things well they be
they build guns artillery and they build
tanks they can't build but can't make
boots they can't make radios they can't
make aluminium they can't make local
motors will do that and specialized the
economy and that will wear out the Third
Reich and that is why 27 million
Russians died and four hundred and five
thousand Americans and four hundred
three hundred and eighty five thousand
British so we said we're going to use
Soviet manpower to blunt the Third Reich
we have to remember also at the time
there had never been an army I said it
was incompetent maybe it was
logistically but not the German soldier
even on the Western Front in 1944
they've lost three million men they
still killed one and a half million one
and a half Americans for every one they
lost and they killed seven Soviets for
every one they lost so they were a
deadly deadly force the German soldier
and thank God for the Red Army that
dealt with him and then we had to not
that we it was such a brilliant policy
afterwards cuz I said we empowered the
Soviet Union but we had a bad and a
worse choice and I think we took the bad
choice thank you
any final question
okay oh one more provide some comments
from a historical basis on the current
conflict or issues with North Korea in
North Korea yeah
well the problem with North Korea is
that for a variety of reasons we're in
an Orwellian situation where the country
with a second largest number of
deliverable nuclear weapons which is us
six I think at sixty-six thousand nine
hundred feels that it's an existential
danger from a country that might have 11
News now why is that happening and it's
happening for two reasons
we have lost conventional deterrence
because over the last 10 years whether
it was the skedaddle from Iraq in 2011
which created Isis or it was the fake
red lines in Syria or it was the bombing
and going home of Libya I don't know
what that was about or it was the tough
talk about Ukraine and Crimea or whether
it was the five deadlines we gave to
Iran I'm not suggesting we was smart or
stupid to go into these places I'm just
saying it was very stupid to threaten
people without consequences so North
Korea said to itself
they have no deterrence their word we're
not worried about them and then secondly
they posed as that their unhinge that's
a value that's a value in nuclear poker
in other words we're not subject to
deterrence it's because we're so crazy
we're willing to eat grass and lose our
cities to get Portland OR Seattle and we
know that you'll do anything not to lose
Portland or Seattle or San Francisco la
so we needed missile defense and if you
look what William Perry the Secretary of
Defense said under Clinton he said we
could build a very expensive
anti-ballistic missile system but the
idea that North Korea would ever
threaten us the continental United
States that's absurd said that in the
1990s Bill Clinton made fun of Star Wars
and canceled it Brock Obama and the hot
mic with the outgoing Russian president
said I'll be flexible about missile
defense ie I'll cut it if you tell
Vladimir to be
until I get elected so we lost the
chance to have missile defense and we
lost the chance that we're capable of
anything and anything at any given time
and the result was that China's patron
that that basically supplies the
technology in the capital to North Korea
said go ahead we enjoy what you're doing
every once in a while say you're crazy
then threaten the United States and
meanwhile we can go on to our policy of
bullying Taiwan South Korea and Japan so
South Korea North Korea is a big asset
for China what do we do about it now
that we don't have missile defense and
we're not likely to do a preemptive
strike I think we have to really talk
about things that are now favorable
because they're not nuclear war if
nuclear war is a specter you want to do
anything but that I would expel every
Chinese member of the Communist Party
I would expel him from the United States
if he's here I was expelled their
children from all US universities and
relieved me if you go to Stanford
University this number of Chinese
nationals that are there is quite
amazing and I would suggest that if
China if Japan and South Korea want to
go nuclear that's a decision that
they're going to make and then China
would look around and say wow do I
really want nuclear South Korea Japan
Taiwan maybe to join nuclear to Russian
nuclear Pakistan on my borders with a
nuclear Iran that's not such a good
scenario so we've got to be creative and
think the unthinkable if we don't want
to go to war but China is that we is
responsible for it and finally all of
this talk about Russian collusion it
hasn't proved anything but it did prove
one thing we lost a valuable Russian car
they have the largest number of
deliverable nuclear weapons they can be
very effective in joining us on
sanctions and blockades they can get out
of our way in the area they have an
18-mile border with North Korea we could
have made an argument you really want a
thermonuclear weapon going off near your
border and yet we've lost all influence
so with the former Soviet Union and
Blatter more poof so we got to work on
that because we've got to say look
you've got to help us with China because
you don't want these nuclear come
countries that are democratic
pro-american
next to your border have a nuclear
weapon so those are the lessons it's
deterrence deterrence deterrence thank
you very much
thank you everyone for being here a
couple of announcements first there will
be a afterglow reception with
refreshments outside and the lobby down
here and more importantly dr. Hansen's
book based on his lecture tonight the
second world wars is due to be released
October 17th this is just a nun
corrected proof so I'm not at liberty to
share it however is available for
advanced purchase and dr. Hansen will be
signing books plates and so if you're
interested in purchasing a copy you can
have dr. Hansen sign the book plate and
the book will be sent to you through the
mails as soon as it's published so that
will be taking place as well out in the
lobby so we are adjourned thank you for
being here have a good evening
[Applause]
you